what's going on guys today we're going
over the crazy spoilers for
my academia chapter 292 which includes
the battle between shoto and toyotaroki
as well as shiguraki waking up and a
very
unexpected piece of news regarding myrio
tagatta
aka lamelian as usual these are just the
spoilers so
there will be more detail when the
official chapter comes out but until
then this is the best we got
be sure to hit that sub button for more
videos like this and remember that every
sunday on twitch i do a page by page
reaction
to the official translation so it will
be good to see you there
the title of this chapter is a ray of
hope and it starts with a brief
flashback to a few minutes earlier
where best genus was on the jet and
stated his disgust
at dabby turning the whole todoroki
family drama
into an issue for the whole of hero
society genus says that he will not let
things go dabi's way
which is then followed by an image in
the present day of gigantomachia being
tied up
by genus's steel fiber cables this is in
addition to
dabby himself being tied up as well as
shiguraki being tied up and spinner
being tied up
basically you get the idea all the
villains are currently restricted
by best genus upon seeing genus bacago
jumps out of eda's arms with a grin on
his face
i mean despite having his stomach
impaled his mentor is finally alive you
know he's finally got that confirmation
because for the last six months or more
you know genus has been completely
missing
no one even knew if he was alive or dead
so you know back goes very happy to see
him
also this means that bakugou's hero name
will be revealed in the upcoming
chapters
so that'll be pretty interesting as well
the scene moves on to darby
who is visibly shocked that best genius
is still alive
especially as as toyo literally just
told the whole of japan
that beshinas was dead so it's kind of
just like going directly against what
he's told everyone
back when dabby first saw the alleged
body of best genus he commented how he
wasn't sure if it was the real thing
so i guess over time diabetes kind of
convinced himself
that the body must have been real
because hawks is just not able to trick
him
in the present day toya says to genus
that even though he may be alive
at least the truth about endeavor is
still out there and it can't be taken
back
gigantomakia is still tied up on the
ground at this point and spinner
continues his long quest
of trying to wake shiguraki up because
only when shiguraki wakes up
can gigantomachia be given new
instructions to you know do stuff
neduri then approaches the villains
while preparing to attack
but unluckily for her this is the moment
where shiguraki wakes up
and he instantly uses forced quirk
activation
specifically the force quirk activation
is used on derby
to activate his flames which then
proceed to fry nedrae in the process
and we see deku looking up and screaming
at the sight of her being attacked like
this
honestly this was a genius move from
shigaraki
because not only was neduray dealt with
but it seems like the steel beams that
were restricting derby
have now been completely burnt off in
the process of his flames activating
so now he's free to move around again as
negerei falls to the ground
tenya does manage to swoop in and grab
her but we'll have to wait and see
how much she was hurt by those blue
flames moving on
you remember how early in the war
shiguraki released a ton of black nomus
that were just running rampage
according to the spoilers these nomu
have wiped out more than half the heroes
that were sent to stop them
which is then followed by a panel of
several unnamed heroes
lying on the ground just totally
defeated four of these black gnomes then
attempt
to head towards shigaraki whilst other
heroes like vernon are trying to stop
them
after this the manga moves over to the
battle of the todorokis
as shoto confronts his older brother he
asks toya why he sent the villain ending
to attack endeavour
even though natsuo very easily could
have been killed in the process
this is a valid question to ask because
natsuo and toya used to be very close
so it's kind of odd that toyo would
endanger natsuo's life
by sending a villain according to the
unofficial translations
dabi's response to this is that natsuo's
death would have also caused endeavor to
suffer so he didn't mind
i gotta stress that this is the
unofficial translation but if it turns
out to be accurate then
it truly shows us that dabi's hatred for
his father
outweighs pretty much every other
emotion he has you know he'd be willing
to sacrifice his favorite brother
just so endeavour would feel more pain
shoto accurately says that toyo has just
gone crazy
to which his brother calmly agrees and
says he's finally happy
because he can kill shoto there was an
awesome panel of them both attacking
each other whilst activating their
flames
which was then followed by shoto being
burned seemingly losing the battle
whilst dabby whips out another iconic
smile
i don't think this battle is over but it
just seems like dabby is winning for now
whilst this goes on the 4 nomu that i
mentioned earlier
now arrive on the battlefield and izuku
kind of he sees them and he's telling
himself to just get up
he needs to help best genius earlier in
this chapter
deku wanted to get up so he could help
nedrae but his body just wouldn't allow
it
but judging by the way things are going
right now in the next few chapters it's
possible that deku will surpass his
limits and you know start fighting again
the chapter ends with something i
honestly didn't expect to see in this
chapter
and you know what i thought there would
be more build up to it but i'm happy to
see it regardless
as the nomu approach genus we see
mirio's face
pop up from the ground as it did when he
was first properly introduced to the
series
and then he leaps out of the ground and
seemingly punches
several of the black nomu right into the
sky that's right people
lamelian is back and at just the right
time
a while back i did a video on how the
million could return
and my most likely prediction was that
eerie would rewind him at some point but
even
i'm surprised that she did it already i
guess izawa is a great teacher
so his training with erie must have
gotten her to a point of being able to
do this
but still i was imagining that myria was
just at home
watching the war unfold on tv and just
being totally quirkless not able to help
out
but you know what because i love this
character i am happy he's back
and hopefully we'll see a lot more of
him going forward
if you've been watching me for a long
time then you'll know i love this
character
i even interviewed the voice uh the
voice actor for mirio for the english
dub
so believe me when i say i am super
happy he's back i just wasn't expecting
it
in this chapter way back in chapter 246
the final spread of that chapter
foreshadowed many things that have
already happened
and mirio appeared in one of those
panels next to a panel of aries horn
activating
so um clearly this return was on
harukochi's mind for a long time
and it's finally come to fruition let me
know your thoughts down below
are you happy at the return of the
million or do you think it was maybe a
little bit too
soon i'd love to see your thoughts on
this and also remember that on sunday
i'll be doing a live reaction
to the official chapter release so you
don't want to miss that thanks for
watching and until the next one
peace out